was a really great tea that you could
consume on a regular basis in fact you
only need to drink a half a glass of it
per day to create some really
significant effects especially on
cortisol as you may already know
cortisol is the main stress hormone and
a lot of people are being exposed to a
chronic amount of high level cortisol
and here's the problem when you're
exposed to cortisol over a long period
of time it's like being exposed to
insulin over a long period of time your
body starts developing cortisol
resistance just like insulin resistance
and that's a situation where there's a
feedback loop problem so in other words
the receptor is blocked so the signals
don't get back to turn off things and so
the cell actually is suffering from a
cortisol deficiency and so then the
adrenals just start pumping up more and
more and more and more so you have a
situation where you have a lot of
cortisol in the body yet it's not
working so you have all sorts of
problems inflammatory problems stress
problems weight problems
etc etc
but this problem can actually come from
two different ways one is through stress
but the other is not through stress but
just by having a genetic problem with
the enzyme that turns the inactive form
of cortisol into the active form okay so
there's this enzyme that basically does
that and if you have a genetic problem
with that enzyme you can either have two
situations one is that the enzyme is
turned up too much so just the tiniest
bit of stress you get this high level of
cortisol and a lot of problems that are
connected to it on the flip side if you
have this enzyme turned down because of
some genetic weakness or whatever
then it could be the opposite right you
go through stress but you don't get the
benefit of cortisol so it's kind of like
having cortisol resistance so both of
these problems really give you the same
bad problems the where I got this
information is I was recently
um for fun reading this book called
natural products and their drug
Discovery it's a textbook of all sorts
of research on how they develop drugs
and what's interesting is about 50 to 70
percent of drugs that were developed
were derived from plant compounds and so
I was looking in the area of stress and
I found this one phytonutrient that had
some significant
potent effects to inhibit the enzyme
okay that converts the inactive to the
active form of cortisol and so some of
the comments in the book were like this
could be a therapeutic Target
to replace some drugs that do this with
virtually no side effects and of course
it's not going to happen because there's
no money in it and you can't patent this
but I'm going to make you aware of this
one phytonutrient that can potently help
you reduce cortisol I first want to just
mention all the effects that can happen
if you have too much cortisol in the
body whether you're experiencing stress
or have a problem with this Gene so
number one you could experience
depression
anxiety you can also experience more
belly fat okay because these receptors
for cortisol are in the belly as well so
you could be just pumping out all this
cortisol and getting fat the medical
term for a cortisol is called
glucocorticoids it's because it's
involved with glucose so when you're in
a state of stress your body is not going
to be running on fat it's going to be
running on glucose like quick energy
cognitive problems relating to your
focus memory concentration and this also
is related to metabolic syndrome and
that's a combination of midsection fat
high blood sugars which is kind of
diabetes or pre-diabetes and then also
hypertension and then also High lipids
like LDL cholesterol things like that
all of that coming from high cortisol
and high sugar another one polycystic
ovarian syndrome okay which is an
androgen problem in females where
they're getting facial hair and
midsection weight in a deeper voice is
really coming from high levels of
cortisol
could come from a diet Problem by
consuming too many carbs or experiencing
too much stress okay now another problem
that's actually quite common is bone
loss after you go through menopause and
that could come from either this genetic
problem or high levels of cortisol
cortisol is very destructive to your
bones so that's going to put the person
at risk for fractures and of course the
person also is going to develop insulin
resistance not necessarily from sugar
but from the stress so
what is this phytonutrient okay well it
is e g c g in green tea okay now that
run so green tea is what you need to
start drinking on a regular basis you
just need a little bit but consistently
just drink it every day and it's an
inexpensive thing it's easy to do and it
can greatly help you reduce cortisol in
a potent way there are a few other
things they mentioned in this book that
can also inhibit and that enzyme called
11 beta hydroxy steroid
dehydrogenase type 1. now you can sound
very very smart at a party but here are
the other things you could actually do
licorice curcumin which is good for just
about everything and also emotein in
Japanese not wheat so there you have it
some really great information on a
natural way to lower cortisol without
all the side effects if you have not
seen my video on the acupressure
technique to lower cortisol you have to
check that one on mix and I put that
video up right here